just the notion of the Speaker of the
House withholding his support for the
nominee of his party presumptive nominee
is that a big deal or not Indiana was
two days ago
and the the call for party unity is
perfunctory but it's premature primaries
are always emotional and this one is
particularly emotional because
mainstream Republicans regular
Republicans and certainly conservative
Republicans are very angry at the party
so my analysis is that Paul Ryan is
speaking to conservatives and saying
look we understand that you're not above
you're not about a party or a person
you're about principles and he would
like to hear from Donald Trump as many
of us would like to particularly we who
have rear edge' stirred as libertarians
more about his policy prescriptions I
don't think he has to undo anything he
has to flesh out some principles that
comport with why people have supported
the Republican Party in the past Mary
when did you rear edge' stir his
libertarian and where do you stand on
voting for Trump or not I'm a never
Hillary and I'm a provisional Trump
because I like his attitude
I like his strategic hutzpah I like that
he had the the gall to to put my macro
messaging over micro-targeting and I
like what I know of his economic policy
I just don't know enough and I think he
could not only win he could win in a
landslide if he would stop his high
school boy antics with women otherwise
gonna force the suburban women to
Hillary I think he can peel off some
african-americans some non-traditional
millennial voters if he find the jobs
message I think he'd be great if he
rains it in a little bit just know we
got him go break real quick with Mary
Yuri registered as a libertarian when
today and why did you do that because I
made I'm a Republican in the
Jeffersonian Madisonian sense I not a
Republican for a party or a person and
the libertarian party represents
continues to represent those those
constitutional principles that I agree
with so Yuri registered at least in part
over the specter of the fact that that
Trump is now the presumptive nominee the
timing is not the time he's not
coincidental here is this he's trying to
steal
headlines away from is there no
connection in your view between Trump
being the presumptive nominee and your
leaving the Republican Party no
connection
I'm not let me make this clear mark and
my friends there
I am never Hillary I'm always Liberty I
as you know and I've said it publicly
here in many places after two successive
blowout elections for conservatives with
a non response from Washington a lot of
conservatives are angry with the party
the party was falling apart I can still
vote for Republicans I will never vote
for Hillary never Trump means always
Liberty Mary had left libertarian left
the Republican Party in national I'm a
provisional Trumpster I don't know
enough about Trump I know like three
things about his economic policy and if
he know everything we need to know about
if your husband's Democratic Party would
you think that's a big story I think it
would be a juicy story for me and it
would just it would contribute mightily
to marital tranquility else's